other news here at 11 o'clock a
residential complex that houses dozens
of las vegas veterans has a pretty grim
future the non-profit running share
village recently released the property
due to covet christian casadas explains
what residents of the low-income
development could be facing next
i spoke to arnold stock who has
spearheaded share village over the years
he tells me kovid really has impacted
his health and is preventing him from
continuing operation that means changes
need to happen the supportive housing
and resources for the elderly issued a
release on tuesday acknowledging stocks
health conditions they notified ysbm
investments in august about the
situation
that company went to court but were
denied by clark county district court
sheriff stated they are optimistic why
sbm will care for the tenants and the
property one veteran resident says she's
very concerned over her future and the
rest of the community these are vietnam
veterans you know they've defended our
country
you know they're not criminals these are
these are elderly people that need our
help we have to take care of them gloria
smith has been living at share village
since the beginning of august but last
month was notified about a transition
smith says that never happened and now
the future of about a hundred and fifty
vulnerable veterans is grim well share
also stated that it will continue to
reduce its day-to-day operations of
property management christian casa is
live local now
a couple final notes here according to
legal document share village owes more
than 50 thousand dollars in overdue
utilities and all of the extended
services it had like the food pantry and
the job resources center the crisis
intervention all that also in limbo the
leasing company which owns the land
claims it's simply not equipped to run a
non-profit